All right, next question.
From Facebook, Rebecca
Eleanor Pfeiffer asks,
"Why V-necks?
"What do you have against
round-collared shirts?"
Rebecca on Facebook is
asking me why I don't wear
what we call crew-neck T-shirts,
you can call them round-collar shirts
if you want a more convoluted
way to describe it,
but maybe that blame goes
to Rebecca and not you,
maybe I'm being unfair in the situation.
Rebecca, those are
called crew-neck shirts,
with all due respect, and
I'm wearing one right now.
I also wear V-necks at
times, it's really a question
of releasing heat.
Okay, now the human body's
internal core temperature
is 98.6 degrees as we all
know, even though nothing
else around us is that temperature.
That means that we are raising
our own core temperature
and expending energy in doing so.
That energy normally comes
from the food that we eat.
We also sometimes, if
we cover ourselves with
too many clothes or a
jacket that's too thick
we may say, "This makes me hot."
In fact, the jacket or the
blanket doesn't make you hot
as much as it prevents you
from releasing your own heat.
You understand, your body
internally is 98.6 degrees.
My responsibility to stay at an externally
comfortable temperature
is to release that heat
into the environment.
If I'm covered, it impedes that release,
which could be beneficial
in a cold climate.
In that case you don't
want to release your heat
because you can't make
the heat quickly enough
to counteract the cold of the environment.
However, in a hotter environment you do
want to release that heat,
and the way you do that
is by exposing as much
of your skin as possible
to the environment.
And short-sleeve shirts
are a way to do that.
Shorts are a way to do
that, and a V-neck T-shirt
is another way to do that,
by exposing the area of my
neck to the environment
I am releasing more heat.
So it's not a fashion choice, it is a
temperature choice for you.
It's a body choice.
It's a physiological
rather than fashion-based.
I think the fit of a T-shirt
is a very critical thing.
In what way?
Well, in the same way
that the simplest pastas
are the most difficult
to cook, the simplest
articles of clothing are
often the most complex
when it comes to the
subtleties of them, and I think
the fit of a T-shirt, between
the shoulders, the chest
and the waist, that holy triumvirate
is a delicate combination.
And if a certain brand
fits you, you may not care
whether it's a crew-neck or a V-neck.
Now, can you, if you will, just cast
your critical eye upon this T-shirt.
I'm gonna do a quick slow-motion turn.
What do you think about this shirt here?
You know, even if you had
turned more quickly I would
have had the acuity to
follow and form an opinion.
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna tell you that
first we need to talk about
your body before we talk about the shirt,
because every shirt fits
differently on different bodies.
The question is how well
does that shirt fit your body
and what is the ratio between
your chest, your waist
and your shoulders?
I can tell you that if I
were to cast a critical eye
I would say it fits your waist very well.
Oh.
There's no excess material,
and there's no excess bulk.
Good.
I would say that
you don't have to raise
your hands to the side,
in fact that distorts
the fit of the shirt,
so I would say that with
your arms straight down
it is a little tight in
the pectoralis majoris,
I can see the outline of your right nipple
on my left side.
Oh, god.
I can tell you that in that sense,
it's a little too tight.
Your left pocket distracts
and possibly obscures
that nipple from being visible.
Okay.
However the shoulders
seem to fit perfectly,
and all in all I'd say
it's a valiant effort,
the problem for you is the chest area.
And again, that's only a
credit to you and how much
you've built those chest muscles up.
If your chest muscles weren't as strong
the shirt would fit
better, but at what price.
So you're saying, basically,
it's shoulders good,
waist good, nipples too tight.
Nipples visible.
Now I'm not gonna say that's too tight,
I'm gonna say that it's tight,
and the nipples are visible.
If that's a stylistic choice
or a choice that you prefer,
that's fine as well, in that
case you have succeeded.
We all have our own personal
sense of style, and if that's
how you choose to express
yours that's fine.
I didn't want my nipple,
you know, I don't think
about my nipples that often.
So you're saying ideally
your nipples would
not be visible.
Well, yeah, I don't want
people looking at my nipple.
I'm not saying people are
looking at it, I'm only saying
it's visible.
People can decide what
they choose to look at,
if someone wants to look at
your elbow or your sternum.
Why do men still have nipples anyway?
I don't use these nipples for anything.
Well you do understand
that human evolution
is thousands of years
behind societal advances.
I mean do you understand
why people have cravings
for food and cravings to
eat more than they should
for optimal health is based on evolution,
a period when your next
meal wouldn't necessarily
come for days and you would
need large amounts of calories
to support large bursts of
energy for fight or flight.
Right.
Well. Okay.
Well, Jordan, thank you
so much, this was very
enlightening in every possible
way, thank you for taking us
through your office, and you
guys, you can follow Jordan
on Instagram and Snapchat
@jordanschlansky,
it's spelled just like it sounds,
and, yeah, always a pleasure.
Thanks.
This has been a mutually
satisfying experience.
I'll see myself out.